A little while ago, we saw these two equations. And even though they look
really different, we mentioned that they are equivalent to one another. We also
saw that this equation over here on the right, written in this particular form,
became very useful when we looked at the quadratic equations that go along with
these equations for parabolas. These two equations are also equivalent. But
the equation 0 equals negative one-eighth times the quantity x minus 4,
times the quantity x minus 28, is very useful to us because from it,
we can just read off the locations of the x intercepts. We have one at x equals
4, and we have another at x equals 28. Now we were just looking at this equation
to help us deal with the expanding dimensions of Grant's growing floor space.
We had 0 equals x squared plus 25x minus 150.
What kind of equation is this, though? Is this a linear equation, or
is it an equation for a parabola? Or is it a quadratic equation?